[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com in extremely not surprising
news to start with today contrary to
what the Trump is right and even some
people on the Left have been saying some
investigators of Robert molars are now
saying that the four-page letter that
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
bar put out does not accurately portray
their findings this is it's so obvious
and it was always so obvious that I'm
kind of embarrassed that there's even a
debate about this within the left like I
knew obviously when William bar wrote
this political press release of a letter
we knew it was meant to be used to have
a victory lap sort of exoneration party
by Donald Trump and the people around
him obviously it made no sense at
minimum because one of the few molar
quotes that was actually in bars letter
actually says molar was not able to
exonerate Donald Trump from obstruction
obviously Trump and people around him
eventually understood that the molar
report isn't so great for Trump because
they shifted from being all about
transparency and the release of the full
report to trying to obstruct its release
within the Senate at the Justice
Department and it absolutely every level
now I got some calls last week and I got
some emails this week that say David
don't you think that if the bar letter
mischaracterizes the molar report molar
would be out there front and center
saying they're not telling the truth and
the answer as I told one of our callers
last week is no molar said nothing the
entire probe molars spokesperson
clarified one news report by saying some
of the descriptions of specific
testimony supposedly made
to the special counsel are not totally
accurate that's all we heard from Robert
Muller's spokesperson during the entire
investigation
Moeller has not spoken there's no reason
to think molar all of a sudden is going
to start speaking unless he has to
testify before the house which he might
and we'll get to that next week but a
New York Times report now says that
molars investigators are not staying
silent
unlike molar himself and they are saying
what anybody with any common sense has
known for two weeks now which is that
the molar report is worse for Trump than
bar claims and it's definitely worse for
Trump than Trump claims now I told you
last week and I told you again this week
the whole point of this bar letter is to
first create a narrative ok bar creates
a narrative a story with this letter
which Donald Trump then uses to run
around the country claiming that he's
been exonerated the right-wing media
Falls for it most corporate media Falls
for it even some left-wing media Falls
for it and now here come his
investigators molars investigators and
they say you know we're concerned
because now William bar has created the
first narrative he got the first
perspective out even though it's not an
accurate perspective the public might be
set in the belief that this is the
narrative the public has been primed and
you have other investigators now saying
shockingly right a lot of the material
in the Moller report should have been
included in that four-page summary if we
wanted it to be an actual complete
representation of what it is that the
investigation found and of course once
again this is all exactly according to
plan and completely unsurprising I think
the phrase you used yesterday Pat but
Pat was primed the pump this is now a
situation where of course the report is
more damaging to Trump than Barr claims
but they have all successfully primed
the pump where I don't even know if the
full truth of the Moller report will be
believed when it finally comes out if it
does well I suppose there's a range of
possible
here like one on one side you have the
bar letter being pretty accurate right
and the 400 pages mostly has to do with
Russia interfering in the election not
so much Russia colluding with Trump on
the other end of the spectrum there is
this idea that Muller had a good amount
of evidence but not quite enough to
indict Trump and he had quite a bit of
evidence on obstruction of justice - but
just didn't want to make the
recommendation wanted to leave that up
to someone else so I mean we won't know
for sure until the Miller report comes
out but certainly this story suggests
that it's the truth is far more on one
side of the spectrum than the other yeah
only in a fantasy world of blinding
political partisanship or deliberate
malignant ignorant could someone think
anything other than it's got to be worse
than Barr said you don't need 400 pages
to say Trump did nothing wrong you don't
say that you can't clear Trump of
obstruction if Trump did nothing wrong
and barn you this so they got a summary
out that was as good as possible for
Trump they used it to create a national
media tour of this faux victory lap
exoneration stuff while working to
stifle the release of the report and
here we are today were even some people
on the left think that the report has
vindicated Donald Trump this was bars
job bar was chosen as Attorney General
because he doesn't believe a president
can be indicted for obstruction and to
cover up the results of the probe he's
done it period and now Democrats are
going to need to keep fighting to get
the full report released which is what I
want to talk about next you can't fault
Democrats for trying even though now
Donald Trump and everyone around him has
been shifting from release the report
it'll be great for us to maybe don't
release it because it's not going to be
quite so great for us Democrats in the
House are doing what they can to get an
unredacted version of the report and the
House Judiciary Committee has authorized
the approval of supriya of subpoena
power to try to force the Justice
Department to give him the report this
is a really big deal but it's also I
don't want to overstate it it's
important to understand this is no
guarantee that Democrats in the House
are actually going to get that
unredacted version of the report with
the house come
has done so far is authorized the
chairman congressman Jerry Nadler to use
a subpoena to get the report if he wants
to and maybe it won't be needed okay
chairman Nagler is saying he's first
going to give William Barr the
opportunity to change his mind and
provide an unredacted report if he
doesn't then the authorization has
already been given to nade ler to use
the subpoena power to try to get an
unredacted version of the report before
we even go into the analysis this is why
controlling the house matters this was a
party-line vote in the House Committee
Democrats control the house meaning they
control the committee they had a
majority we might never get the full
report even with Democrats controlling
the house you can be sure that if
Democrats did not control the house we
would have no chance of getting this
report in close to an unredacted form so
that's a big deal
now it's not making as many headlines
but also important and approved are
subpoenas for five former White House
staffers that Democrats want to talk to
you this includes Steven Bannon the
Trump propagandist this includes Trump's
old White House lawyer Don Magan it
includes one of trumps former White
House communications directors hope
Hicks it includes Reince Priebus and one
other person that could be really
interesting we're going to be following
when they might show up and testify and
in addition to that congressman Richard
Neal friend of the show I've known
Richard Neal for a long time used to be
my congressman and he's been on the
program before he is using a very
specific method that tax related
committees have to request financial
documents directly from the Treasury and
he has done so with some number of years
of Donald Trump's tax returns whether
the Treasury will turn them over we
don't know but this is why it matters
that Democrats controlled the house the
to go back to the report briefly there
is a concern that the version remember
William bar said he would give a version
of the report to the house there are
real concerns that the redactions are
going to be completely
off the wall bonkers because there is
this category that William Bar said
would be redacted which is anything that
quote would unduly infringe on the
personal privacy and reputational
interests of peripheral third parties
the reputational interests of peripheral
third parties that is so absurdly broad
and open to extreme political
manipulation that we have to deal with
that Democrats are saying we will deal
with it with subpoenas if we need to and
Republicans are going to do exactly what
we've predicted which is drag this out
as long as possible they'll make the
house wait as long as possible to figure
out what it is that William bar will
give them maybe it's mid-april maybe
mid-april turns into later April or
early May and let them subpoena the
report and eventually put out something
extraordinarily redacted and fight the
subpoenas themselves by then it could be
closer to 2020 which I want to remind
you is why we vote once again if
Democrats didn't control the house there
wouldn't even be the possibility of a
subpoena to get the report since
Republicans don't want it and
Republicans voted against it in the
committee which is reinforcing why what
matters most right now is voting in 2020
to get these people out will we get the
unredacted report or not tell me what
you think i'm on twitter at a Pakman and
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Colin Damon Colin thank you so much
for being our newest david pakman show
member of the day also want to say
thanks to Marnell steiner Marnell has
been a member for almost 5 years dating
back to 2014 and is today's longtime
sustaining member of the day Colin and
Marnell thank you support the work that
we do it's really easy it's really cheap
you go to WWE at mancom and you just
sign up and then before you know it I'm
telling you that you've been with us
five years and you're the longtime
sustaining member of the day it's a
beautiful thing and appreciate everybody
who signed up in the month the first few
days of April so far ok I invite you to
discuss the topics of the David Pakman
show and other political topics on our
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
IDI di t spotted a couple of interesting
discussions this morning that i wanted
to point out to you one of which relates
to health insurance which is a very
interesting comment from a british
viewer who says as a Brit it's mind
boggling that people say but Sir what
about the insurance companies as if it's
more or as important than actual effing
lives yeah this is something you know I
it's perfectly reasonable to say you
know the reality is that right now a lot
of people work for insurance companies
and a lot of people work in medical and
insurance billing so if we drastically
changed our health insurance system to
one that gives everybody coverage and it
kind of disconnects the payment systems
that we have from the ability to receive
care could be Medicare for all it could
be a nationalized system whatever I get
it a lot of people who work in health
insurance health insurance companies
medical billing and all of that
bureaucracy are going to lose their jobs
isn't saving people more important than
propping up an industry that shouldn't
even exist this is sort of
with coal right yeah coal miners are
going to lose their jobs and they're
gonna have to find other jobs and some
of them are going to have difficulty
doing that and as an economy as a
country as a society we'll have to
figure out how to support them but isn't
getting rid of dirty polluting coil a
coal a higher and more important
priority than saving those jobs and it's
stunning to me when people concern troll
around insurance companies that are
making profit off of providing people
health care simply so that they can live
good lives and I get it as an American
you don't have to be a Brit as an
Argentinean American I completely have
the the exact same point of view also
from the david pakman show subreddit joe
biden advisors are mad at bernie sanders
his team over allegations yes so i have
no reason at this point to believe that
this is true but it's being asserted
that the recent string of women who say
joe biden made them uncomfortable by how
he hugged them for example there have
been assertions made that it's the
Bernie Sanders campaign that has been
getting those women to make these
assertions and putting that together for
the time being Pat I've not seen any
actual evidence of that although it's
been asserted numerous times have you
heard anything about it beyond just the
allegation no I haven't and I'm not
entirely sure that allegations against
Joe Biden would help Bernie Sanders he's
like on the one hand I understand Joe
Biden is leading in most of the polls
even though he hasn't announced yet but
on the other hand I think Bernie Sanders
and his supporters want a bunch of
establishment Democrats to run because
then they would split up the vote
amongst one another and allow Bernie a
path to the nomination so I'm interested
in looking and learning more about this
for sure yeah that's interesting yeah I
agree it's not totally clear that just
attacking Biden is the best thing for
Bernie anyway not to mention that unless
we have evidence that he did it we
really shouldn't be saying it those
discussions and many more on the David
Pakman show subreddit david pakman.com
slash re d di t okay I hate that I have
to do this today and I was hoping Monday
Tuesday that I wouldn't have to but I
have to okay YouTube ad pocalypse 2.2
point
might be starting now if you're
wondering 2.0 what was 1.0 almost two
years ago to the day March 31st 2017 a
very very dark day in David Pakman show
history and in youtube history ad
pocalypse 1.0 started and what triggered
it was an ad for coca-cola appeared on a
racist ad a racist video on youtube that
had about 800 views advertisers flipped
out saying if YouTube can't make sure
our ads don't show up on racist content
we're pulling our money out of YouTube
some actually did and as a result
YouTube drastically overreacted cut
almost all ads to news and politics
channels like the David Pakman show
and overnight we lost 99% of the revenue
on our YouTube channel revenue that we
had come to rely upon disaster now we
had a slow recovery over time we had
many more D monetization 's and still do
but our channel continued to grow
so our YouTube channel still to this day
makes less money than it did before ad
pocalypse but we had three hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers when at
apocalypse 1.0 hit we now have six
hundred and twenty thousand so it's been
we've worked our asses off to grow the
channel just to close the gap
in revenue that resulted from ad
pocalypse 1.0 but we thought things had
stabilized until this week this week we
have started to see what some are
calling a soft news and politics D
monetization others are straight up
calling it at apocalypse 2.0 this is
happening instead of at the channel
level like we saw two years ago it's
happening at the video level and I'll
explain to you with examples how this is
happening we put out our video for
example commenting on Monday on the
candice owens dave rubin interview
Candice Owens interviewed Dave Rubin we
commented on that interview that video
was marked demonetized now there's
nothing in that video that is
not FCC friendly there's nothing in the
video that's not brand safe it's me
talking about an interview with simple
basic uncontroversial language the video
published Monday afternoon and was
instantly demonetised now I contact
YouTube YouTube says David no problem
just appeal the decision and a real
person will review it which we do but
the review process can take anywhere
from two to seven days the first 48
hours of a videos life are the most
important because that's when a majority
of the views are happening and case in
point 48 hours after we published the
video I get an email from YouTube saying
hey great David great news
monetization has been turned back on
except the first 48 hours have elapsed
and we've earned no money on that video
next example a video titled Trump
suddenly against releasing the Moller
report this is a video from yesterday's
show where we talked about the legal
comings and goings of Donald Trump and
Robert Muller and William Barr lots of
legalese and discussions of what is and
isn't and William bars four-page letter
it's not gory it's not racy it's not
sexual or outrageous or off of brand
safety but the video was at least
initially marked as possibly
inappropriate for some u're some viewers
on the basis of their age and it would
pop up something you had to click on and
acknowledge that even though this might
be inappropriate for some users you want
to watch it anyway
this isn't d monetization but these age
limited videos are disadvantaged in the
algorithm they get fewer views and we
get screwed again with a video that
quite frankly has no basis whatsoever
for being marked as for mature audiences
only or whatever phrase you want to
apply to it example number three we did
a video on Monday about Jordan Peterson
Peterson spoke at Liberty University on
a panel we commented on it nothing
remotely controversial no bullying no
mean pranks no swearing no nudity
nothing but as you can see from the
yellow dollar sign instead of green in
our video control panel which were
showing our video audience it was D
monetized we appeal it it takes two days
and the appeal comes back as yes this
cannot be monetized hi David Pakman show
after manually reviewing your video
we've confirmed that it isn't suitable
for all advertisers as a result it will
continue to run limited or no ads a
video where I just talk about whether
Jordan Peterson is or isn't a political
figure it's video of him sitting at
Liberty University talking not monetized
this could be the new ad pocalypse this
could be ad pocalypse 2.0 so here's what
I want to do um I refuse to start
picking topics for the David Pakman show
based on what's going to monetize it's a
disservice to you it's not how I run the
show it's not how I've ever run the show
plus at this point who even knows what's
going to be monetized on the basis of
this wacky algorithm last time we were
sort of slow on the uptake when this
happened and we fell behind financially
and had some calamities as a result I'm
asking for you to help us not need the
YouTube revenue get a membership on our
website okay the memberships are really
cheap its cheapest two bucks a month if
you use the right coupon code almost all
of the money comes to us there are
platforms out there that keep 5% of what
you contribute there are platforms out
there that keep 10% of what you
contribute YouTube super chats 30% goes
to YouTube when you begin a membership
on our website 2.9 percent pays for the
credit or debit card fee we get the rest
okay almost all the money comes to us go
to WWE at muncom there are memberships
for every budget any membership is great
if you pay 60 bucks for the year or 6
for the month or whatever it all helps
ok you get the bonus show you get the
other perks and you're supporting us but
most importantly we do not want to be
even remotely can
during what is going to monetize on
YouTube when we consider what it is that
we should cover on the show we cover
what I think is worth covering and
that's the way we want to keep it we
have two discounts that are available I
know that six bucks a month or 60 for
the year is a lot of money for many
people so let's just drop the prices if
you want us to drop them the coupon code
this is 20 20 will save you 40% off of
any membership $6 a month becomes three
dollars and 60 cents a month $60 a year
becomes $36 per year this is 20 20 will
work on any membership and lastly if you
want to get a year membership for 25
bucks one payment 25 bucks that's like
two dollars a month two dollars and
eight cents a month use the coupon code
save 35 on the $60 membership it will
only work on the $60 membership on code
save 35 it'll drop the $60 membership to
just 25 bucks two dollars and eight
cents a month for hundreds of hours of
content that keeps us independent so I'm
asking for your support we are extremely
worried about what maybe ad pocalypse
2.0 incoming and I will keep you updated
as I did throughout pocalypse 1.0 and
hopefully this is not going to be nearly
as bad as some of the red flags suggest
that may be getting okay let's take a
quick break next I will speak to Igor
Volsky
about gun safety and much much more
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to be joined
today by Igor Volsky who's the
co-founder and executive director of
guns down America and author of the book
guns down how to defeat the NRA and
build a safer future with fewer guns
Igor thanks for joining me to talk about
this thank you so much for having me so
to start with one of the things I've
been talking about when it comes to gun
safety regulations is that on the one
hand you have extremely both sort of
fetishized and emotional reactions to
the issue of gun safety from a
significant portion of the population
but at the same time in a lot of places
people are not voting on the basis of
gun safety proposals from candidates so
there's this kind of strange dichotomy
where on the one hand people have
extremely strong views on this issue on
the other hand it's not clear that it's
a voting issue and it leads to I believe
those who are advocating for increased
gun safety regulations at a fundamental
disadvantage do you agree with my sort
of structural framing or disagree well
David one of the most interesting things
I learned when writing guns down was
this new research that analyzed how the
NRA communicated to its members and what
it discovered is that the NRA uses very
emotional terms terms that suggest a
certain identity and so gun ownership
for a lot of the NRA followers or some
portion of the NRA followers isn't just
about the intricacies of policies it's
literally tied in and intertwined with
their identities of who they are and and
the NRA typical
describes gun owners as these good
law-abiding entirely patriotic citizens
and of course describes the other side
of this issue as the folks who want to
take guns away and get government into
your life and it's that kind of frame
that they've been using really since
1977 in a big way that creates that kind
of emotional connection and that creates
as you point out a clear connection
between the hardcore NRA members and
then how they vote on this issue so they
vote on guns in a way that the other
side doesn't now that's changing on the
gun control side but it's gonna take
some time and of course the gun control
side our side I'd say talks about this
issue in facts and figures and in all of
these wonky ways that really doesn't
resonate as well as the emotional
identity terms that the NRA uses so I
think that's a big part of why we see
that kind of divide so think back to
after the Sandy Hook shooting there was
I mean in a sense the gun safety
advocates more or less did a lot of the
right things there was a horrible mass
shooting there was a sort of coalescing
of opinion that it's time to at minimum
past universal background checks on any
gun transaction doesn't matter if it's
private at a gun show you just a hundred
percent there was 85 to 90% of agreement
on that from Americans which means that
that's that's some Democrats and some
Republicans and some independents it
crosses party lines and still it wasn't
done who and and when did the failure
who failed and why did that fail to take
place even when it seemed as though the
conversation was going in the right
direction
people were relatively united on that
issue what went wrong well look that was
certainly a major disappointment I
remember the day the vote ultimately
failed we were in
in a restaurant with survivors who
worked so hard to try to get it across
the finish line but in terms of what
actually happened it's an interesting
story because initially after Newtown
there was this real sense even among
Republicans that now with twenty
children gunned down six staff members
gunned down in Newtown that something
was actually going to change and you had
Republican members of Congress
particularly in the Senate saying all
right I think I can support this you had
at the very beginning the NRA at the
table helping right what eventually
became the manchin-toomey bill as that
was happening that of course is the bill
that ultimately failed as that was
happening as the manchin-toomey bill was
being put together by senators joe
Manchin and Pat Toomey a Republican and
the Democrats was a bipartisan effort
the gun owners of America which is a
even more conservative gun rights group
than the NRA got wind of the fact that
the NRA was helping put together this
measure and began making a lot of noise
and saying the NRA isn't the real
organization that's protecting your gun
rights it's us gun owners of America and
the NRA
never wanting to be outflanked told back
in the entire effort crumbled and it
partly crumbled because of the poll that
the NRA has with Republican members of
Congress to whom it gives thousands of
dollars in contributions and and who had
helps elect and so that's the dynamic
that occurred it surprised a lot of
people that we were so close to possibly
getting something done there was a true
bipartisan effort and then it crumbled
given the internal politics in the gun
rights movement well it's not even just
just the internal politics because the
internal politics would matter less if
in general the gun lobby had less
influence less money and and less power
so what do we do about that
because the Geo a versus NRA dispute is
relevant only if as a lobbying group
they have power so I feel like it's a
more systemic a problem that we're
dealing with well it is a more systemic
problem but I'll also say that the gun
control movement has really evolved from
where they were in Newtown to where they
are today after parkland to a place
where you have organizations like mine
guns down America that are calling for
far bolder solutions to reduce gun
deaths that's arguing that what we
really need to do to solve this problem
is to create a future with fewer guns a
future where guns are significantly
harder to get we're arguing that it's
not a problem of the bad guys having
guns but it's the guns themselves that
are the problem and we need to change
the environment for everybody in which
the the environment in which guns are
purchased that needs to be strengthened
the standard for gun ownership needs to
increase that's a big evolution from
where we were in 2013 when the
background check bill failed and it's a
real maturity I think in the gun control
movement and it's a change in dynamic
and so I think moving forward
particularly when you saw after Parkland
all of those companies I think was about
40 companies that broke ties with the
NRA yeah we just launched a campaign
this morning in the New York Times
that's gonna push the largest public
facing banks to stop doing business with
the gun industry until that industry is
fundamentally reformed that's a new area
of advocacy that seeks to drain the gun
industry seeks to drain the NRA that did
not exist in Newtown so I'm actually
fairly optimistic I mean I take your
point about the dynamics but I think the
movement is so much stronger today in
2019 than it was in 2013 so let's talk
about some let's drill into like one
nitty gritty element of this that I
think the gun safety crowd is not always
completely united on not because a
of anything other than it's a complex
issue which is let's talk about types of
firearms okay we know that as a few data
points on the one hand a lot of the more
publicized mass shootings involve what
are called assault style rifles we know
that statistically most gun homicides
are actually handguns in situations
where one or two people are either
injured or killed then there is the
counter to that which is yes but a lot
of those are suicides and it's not
actually people going out and harming
others what do you recommend and you
outline this new Second Amendment
compact which we can sort of talk about
in cut this context what is your
suggestion as to what the gun safety
advocate position should be on types of
firearms
well first David let me say you keep on
saying gun safety I would suggest the
term gun control because guns are
inherently dangerous really in anyone's
hands which is why I'm suggesting we
increase the standard for gun ownership
I want to control guns now to find a way
to make those guns safer well I think
it's about when I say gun safety I mean
make make the country safer that's fair
that's fair in terms of what I want to
see and the new second amendment compact
you know they're I think 13 in the in
the final version different policies
that I put forward but it's really
easier to break them up into three
different buckets in all of those
buckets I'll say point towards a single
long-term goal of building a future with
fewer guns and and they look like this
and they go after by the way as you
point out the homicides the suicides
than the mass shootings so bucket number
one is really regulating the gun
industry in a real way right now the
products that they produce are entirely
unregulated
and what happened was in the late 1980s
and early 90s the gun industry made a
decision to begin producing militarized
weapons for the civilian market that's
how you got the assault weapons but just
as importantly that's how you got
militarized hand
that use larger rounds those rounds are
coming at you faster and what we're
seeing in some cities across America is
that folks are dying from bullet wounds
that they were surviving with past
generations of guns that's a big problem
that needs to change and the reason why
they're exempt by the way is because of
an amendment that the late John Dingell
put forward now his wife who holds his
seat wants to plug that hole she has
legislation to do that that's a good
idea
so that's bucket number one really
cracking down on the industry it also of
course includes repealing placa which is
that law that gives broad immunity two
into two to the gun manufacturers and to
dealers bucket two focuses on making
guns significantly harder to get that's
where I talked about raising the bar for
gun ownership and what I mean by that is
if you choose to own a gun you should
have to go to your local police
department get fingerprinted pass a
written test pass a field test pass a
comprehensive background check get
insurance on the firearm you're gonna
purchase have a waiting period between
when you apply for the license and then
when you get the license and then only
then can you get a gun and you also then
have to register that gun now there's a
system in Massachusetts that's very
similar to what I'm describing I was
going to mention that here in Boston if
I want a firearm I actually have to go
and meet with the police and demonstrate
to their satisfaction that I have a
particular particular need for it so -
yeah and that's been a terrific model
not just in terms of lowering homicides
but you also point to suicides right
that's two thirds of our gun deaths we
know from research that people commit
suicides during a short window of crisis
and so getting extending the length of
time between when you want a gun and
when you purchase a gun get some out of
that crisis window and saves lives yeah
of course people will say that some of
those people
who were truly committed to taking their
life at that time if there's a waiting
period they'll find some other mechanism
to take their life and of course with
some people that will be true but not
everybody not everybody and you are
going to save some people yeah I mean
you know there's a little literature
literature on suicide is very very rich
and and statistically speaking folks who
try to commit suicide once and are
unsuccessful are in a period of crisis
when they're thinking of committing
suicide
they are far less likely to try again so
yes some people who are determined will
of course find another way but what we
also know is that suicide by gun is far
more fatal than suicide by any other
means combined so the numbers on that
are on that are very very strong and
then the third piece the third bucket
really deals with some of the gun
violence we have in places like Chicago
in Baltimore in Philadelphia what we
have in those cities are very specific
areas and very specific individuals that
you could literally circle on the map
and figure out where they are street by
street block by block and those folks
are responsible for the overwhelming
majority of the gun deaths that are
happening in those cities and since
about the 1990s what we've had are
community based violence intervention
programs that are operating in all of in
many of these cities that use folks from
the community to help identify who these
individuals are and to de-escalate the
you know the beefs that they might have
away from guns and into and channel that
into more constructive forms of problem
solving and really changing the norms of
the community and that has been
incredibly successful we've seen success
rates of about 30 to 70 percent of
reducing gun deaths in urban areas those
programs are important and they really
need to be supported with federal
dollars the book is guns down how to
defeat the NRA and build a safer future
with
fewer guns we've been speaking with the
book's author Igor Volsky who's also the
co-founder and executive director of
guns down America
Igor thanks so much for talking to us
about this today thanks so much David
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
Donald Trump's been waging a battle
against alternative energy and against
logic and against reason and he's now
claiming that the noise that wind
turbines make causes cancer which is of
course not true on the basis of anything
that's known to the species Homo sapiens
at this point in time you might remember
that trumps had a long list of bogus
critiques of wind power he recently said
you don't want to rely on wind power
because wind sometimes doesn't blow he's
talked about wind power killing birds
which it does that's true but it kills
them at a lower rate than other energy
sources so recently Trump spoke to
Republicans and he said they say the
noise from wind turbines causes cancer
this is extraordinarily concerning not
only because of what it means with
regard to what we should be doing about
alternative energy and climate change in
pollution in the country but it's also
concerning because it is yet another one
of these data points of posit possible
cognitive decline experienced by Donald
Trump take a look at this video from the
event and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one okay and of
course it's like a graveyard for birds
if you love birds you'd never want to
walk under a window cuz it's a very sad
sad right like a cemetery of course of
course this just isn't true I mean wind
turbine noise does not cause cancer
there are issues with the noise there
can be psychological impacts which you
could maybe extrapolate into physical
health concerns but there's no evidence
that the wind turbine noise causes
cancer and as usual it's projection
even though Trump doesn't realize it
remember that Trump's been trying to
revive the coal industry which is an
industry that does cause cancer coal is
not good for coal miners coal burning
coal is carcinogenic greenhouse gas
emissions huge air pollution all of this
stuff but it seems that Trump just
denies science and wants to revive the
coal industry anyway it's sort of like a
this is what I call the natural news
president or whatever pseudoscience
website you
you want to think about Trump has
dabbled in anti-vaxxer conspiracies he
even tweeted about vaccines causing
autism specifically remember this when
he said back in 2014
healthy young child goes to doctor gets
pumped with massive shot of many
vaccines doesn't feel good and changes
autism many such cases the Obama birther
conspiracy nonsense and now Donald Trump
says that wind turbine noise causes
cancer we have in the White House the
equivalent of the grandmother that's
constantly sharing fake news articles
that she saw on Facebook or the crazy
uncle who forwards without BC seeing
says that the 60 people that he knows
some whacked-out conspiracy that he
picked up on some conspiracy website and
I fought I saw funny interpretation of
the anti wind turbine stuff which is
that if you remember Trump was embroiled
in a controversy in Scotland because
wind turbines were built near Donald
Trump's Scottish golf course or resort
and it supposedly spoiled the view Trump
was furious and maybe this is how he's
taking it out on them by talking about
wind turbine noise causing cancer or
whatever I've truly never understood
that when the Cape Wind project was
being discussed here in Massachusetts
Pat and you had people on Cape Cod
saying I don't want to see that in my
backyard off of my dock a mile or so
away I think it's cool I like the idea
of looking out there and seeing look
it's renewable energy we're actually
doing something to try to stop harming
the planet I've never understood the
people that don't like the look of it I
say put put it put it offshore where I
can see it I love it yeah the arguments
against wind energy are just so bad like
this one in particular that they're
unsightly I don't think they're
unsightly at all I think they look very
cool another one they often go to is
that uh you know if it's not windy that
day then your TV's not going to work or
you're not gonna be able to heat up
something in the microwave like that's
just not how this stuff works and I
think Trump and these other Republicans
really have to get a better
understanding of it before they start
commenting on it yeah of course and you
know when we're talking about wind power
wind power would contribute to
broader electrical grid so that if it's
not blowing exactly at that time that
you need to run your microwave as Donald
Trump has said you have other sources of
electricity at that point in time the
arguments against wind power are really
really bad and I don't know if this is
evidence of Donald Trump's hyper
partisanship when it comes to
alternative energy or cognitive decline
that he would say something so
unbelievably out of place or some
combination of the two I don't know I
have to give you an update about the
continuing back and forth over
intellectual property theft from Sam
cedar some really really ugly
allegations have now surfaced in the
midst of this that my family allegedly
ran to Argentina as Nazis to seek safe
haven in the time after World War Two so
this has really taken an ugly turn first
it was all about my supposed
intellectual property theft of sam
cedars set design then on april 1st
which is irrelevant dates we escalated
by allegedly stealing the design of
sam's
logo that is over his left shoulder
during the program and then also on
april first relevant again that it was
all on april first we published a clip
to our YouTube channel where I mimicked
a Sam cedar segment where he pranked one
of those IRS scammers I pranked one of
those IRS scammers so it's gotten very
very ugly and this caller to Sam's show
Ronald Reagan called into Sam's program
and made the extraordinarily ugly
assertion that my family's presence in
Argentina may have been linked to Nazism
take a listen to this uh just kind of
like unrelated I found out over the
weekend that David Pakman was born in
Argentina
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I thought that's weird what kind of
name is pac-man right pac-man pac-man so
did a little research
pac-man it turns out is the German name
wrong so you know German born and so I'd
heard that pac-man is Jewish so are you
actually suggesting in addition to a
very disturbing familial history some
stolen valor here well I just want to
say like you know it's bad enough that
we have to worry about intellectual
property theft but now we have questions
about all right extremely ugly
allegations Pakman is not a German name
it's a Russian Ukrainian name and I want
to be super clear my family went to
Argentina before the Holocaust my family
is Jewish this is a horrible horrible
smear and in fact my great-uncle was one
of the Mossad operatives involved in
kidnapping Adolf Eichmann from Argentina
okay that last thing wasn't true but I'm
just trying to trigger Ronald Reagan
into looking into more of this stuff I
you know this really is getting very
very ugly and I hope that it stops as I
mentioned I've retained Marky Geragos to
represent me in this entire thing and we
are going to be countersuing both Sam
and Ronald Reagan for defamation and
punitive damages and it's going to get
very very very ugly and I look forward
to a chatting with Sam about it in
person over dinner next week in Las
Vegas even though it's gotten
extraordinarily ugly between the two of
us okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p our
voicemail line is made possible by our
good friends over at linguist linguist
has built a really effective spaced
repetition based language learning app
which is powered by AI i've been using
it to improve my French my French has
always been come see come saw I think is
the right way
I would say it and I'm going to need to
avail myself of my French skills soon
for a work related project that's
bringing me back to France so I've been
using linguist to refresh and improve my
French and it's been very very helpful I
love it and I encourage you to try it
for free no credit card required at Ling
viscom slash Pakman that Ling vist with
a V dot com slash Pakman here is today's
voicemail which is really strange I
don't know what I might have said that
would have triggered a voicemail like
this but a very nice sounding woman
called in with an extraordinarily
specific turkey burger recipe which I
don't think is a phrase that's ever been
said on the program turkey burger but in
any case let's listen okay but my name
is Trish I was just calling because I
was wondering do you love turkey burgers
but you never quite sure know how to
make them well now I can tell you how to
do it it's easy
first just top the burger with one slice
of cheese and heat it until the cheese
melts I'm assuming you've already made
the turkey burger part then what you're
gonna want to do is spread some
mayonnaise on customize the roll or you
could just use regular bread make sure
you layer the bottom bread or half of
the roll with a half a cup of lettuce
one sliced tomato everyone sliced red
onion then you're going to top it with
the burger also you could add two slices
of avocado and two pieces of turkey
bacon if you want to make it really
exciting and enjoy it anyway last step
you're going to want to cover all of
those ingredients with the top of the
roll or other slice of bread anyway make
sure you serve it immediately and enjoy
bye I don't know what to make of this it
actually sounds like a really good
turkey burger the only addition I might
make of some grilled jalapenos I think
would go really well with that uh
the avocado slices and the turkey bacon
but can you think of anything Pat that
would have triggered someone to call in
and it by the way I love the kids
yelling in the background to it just
it's also atmospheric and and lovely I
can't think of any reason why someone
would call this show and leave that rest
although I've made very specific notes
and planned to make that tonight for
dinner well Trish started the voicemail
by saying that she just had this on her
mind that she was just wondering so I
don't think that you suggested anything
that would make it seem like you needed
a turkey burger recipe but I feel like
assembling the burger is the easy part
like the actual preparing the meat would
be the difficult part but hey I'm a
vegan I'm out of my element here
yes she's skipping the most important
part that can make it really good which
is what are you making the burger the
patty itself from are you using a
combination of light meat and dark meat
ground turkey are you mixing in any
little bits of onion are you what what
else are you doing are you making it
more like a meatball including a little
bit of bread crumbs and an egg although
I think quite frankly that might make it
a little heavy to then put between two
pieces of bread with avocado and
mayonnaise I think that that that may be
a little much but in any case love the
recipe
I guess use the voicemail line to leave
me interesting recipes and I will put a
picture up on Instagram if I end up
making this over the weekend on today's
bonus show we will talk about mayor Pete
Budaj edge and some of the articles that
are being written about him and his
campaign and more I think people will
find it interesting we will also on
today's bonus show talk about how six
states plus Washington DC are suing over
changes to school lunch rules what are
those changes I will tell you and lastly
murder charges have been dropped against
the Vietnamese woman allegedly involved
in the death of Kim Jong Un's
half-brother that's a story we've
actually been covering for like it's
been going on for for a couple years at
this point if not longer time flies but
it's not a new story and charges have
now been dropped where do you get to
listen to or watch these stories that
I'm talking about the answer is the
bonus show become a member at WWN
pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
either platform will give you instant
access to the bonus show and a bunch of
other great perks the party doesn't have
to end right now
I'm going to quickly grill up a turkey
burger and then I will be back to host
the bonus show momentarily
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
you
[Music]